lá muito voltar a todos
existe uma grande luz e uma grande
barreira para com vocês não consigo ver
mas vou tentar expressar me da melhor
maneira o meu nome é luiz mattos não vai
fazer magia tanto é típica brincadeira
toda a gente tem a gente faz mas
provavelmente vou vos mostrar coisas que
é de certa forma é tem alguma magia é de
interesse principalmente é magia do
sentimento é e portanto vou tentar
mostrar como é como o percurso é também
me transformou e estou a tentar
transformar a sociedade também
utilizando é algo como a robótica que
por norma têm é um preconceito muito
grande da sociedade a associados e
portanto tem duas batalhas que é tentar
mostrar que é tentar eliminar o
preconceito que existe na cidade para
com as pessoas com mobilidade reduzida e
portanto por outro lado ea urinar o
preconceito que existe para com a
robótica
eu venho desta é uma terra que vocês
viram naquela imagem de cozinha é e
portanto é como vocês podem imaginar
tudo é mais certa forma difícil é quando
é vivo numa cidade do interior numa
cidade mais pequena e quantos têm
deficiência é esta foto foi tirada há
cerca de 19 anos atrás minutos anos e eu
ter ficado nessa cadeira de balanço e
portanto eu sou campanha além do mais é
que vocês podem ver e ganhei
basicamente esta casa e esta nova via é
praticar desporto é sem ter uma causa
prendem entanto os médicos não conseguem
explicar o motivo de histeria consigo
mas a verdade é que fica como usamos lar
completa que me impossibilitou de andar
até hoje forma normal
obviamente que avisa não parou e
certa forma é felizmente tinha uma
família e amigos que disputaram e que
mudaram a estrutura mental psicológica e
também é social
para ultrapassar esta barreira e este
acontecimento é ea vida continua e é ao
longo do deste percurso tentei fazê lo
da forma certa forma normal é sempre as
pessoas que estejam ao meu lado
sinto que eu estou numa cadeira rosas há
coisas que são inevitáveis portanto
subir uma rampa é não existir uma tampa
e portanto precisamos sempre certa forma
de ajuda isso é um dado que nós temos
que assumir quando temos uma limitação
física ou não fica até psicológica e
portanto é assumindo nós esse lado é
esse fator a nossa vida copa com
normalidade dentro do curso académico e
tira engenharia informática cin da
universidade da beira interior na
covilhã é e ao longo desse percurso é no
final desse percurso académico eu tinha
que resolver a minha tese final do curso
de engenharia informática é de certa
forma não muito via nos projetos que os
dois tinham pra mim é tudo muito legal a
tecnologia atualmente muito ligado às
redes sociais é o software e embora eu
seja um consumidor de certa forma eu
gosto vê-los brigar eu gosto de coisas e
mexer efetivamente e portanto sempre fui
um apaixonado pelo olhar do erp e foi
aqui que começou a entrar na robótica e
portanto numa símbolos e das compras
surgiu a ideia z
por que não criar algo como pudesse ser
o tempo assim ainda hoje é impossível
uma pessoa como da dúvida ir às compras
de forma confortável e é uma tarefa tão
diária do normal toda a gente faz e que
ainda hoje não é possível fazê la sempre
ajuda a alguém e isso pessoalmente
e foi aí que surgiu a tecnológica criada
para desenvolver robótica desenvolver
tecnologia que permita ajudar por um
lado
as pessoas mas também por outro lado os
negócios
como é que nós temos vindo a fazer isto
somos já hoje uma equipa de cerca de 500
pessoas com vários prêmios ganhos com
várias capitais riscos associados a nós
é que não tenha estado nesta missão não
é fácil construir robótica a partir do
qual é e nós temos vindo a tentar
conseguir fazê lo em minha tarefa hoje é
mostrarmos um bocadinho com base neste
curso pessoal que se tornou também para
o profissional como é que nós
conseguimos certa forma humanizada à
tecnologia e mostrar aos que
efetivamente robótica não é que o bicho
papão que todos nós imaginamos e
realizamos como mostra um primeiro
projeto que nós desenvolvemos que é o
igual a israel que é um carrinho de
compras completamente autónomo
desenvolvido para auxiliar pessoas como
cuidar produzida é transportar as suas
compras entre uma superfície comercial
é com isto criamos uma tecnologia capaz
de reconhecer em tipicamente uma pessoa
onde a pessoa apenas de se colocar em
frente à nossa equipamento coloca o seu
saco na zona central carrega num botão é
e menos três que o robô consegue
convencê lo por completo e passar a
escola com isso nós vamos efetivamente
liberdade
a pessoa é e independentemente da
condição física que ela possa ter para
utilizar e portanto somos livres
analisamos a verdadeira inclusão que eu
posso ter uma pessoa como gago dia uma
pessoa sem qualquer 110 dívida ou
utilizar o mesmo equipamento que
portanto há uma integração e uma
inclusão plena
por outro lado é fazendo brincadeiras
também naturalmente a quem está entregue
em dia é nós conseguimos fazer robôs que
consigam circular para além de fazer
segmento que consigam circular de um
ponto a 1 ponto e 1 ponto e de forma
completamente autônoma e natural sem ter
que adaptar o espaço center que é fazer
nada especial é só colocar o robô eu
tenha a inteligência ea capacidade de
circular porque quisemos em parceria com
a delta
quisemos mostrar que é possível aliar o
álbum também tradicional com o altamente
tecnológico e portanto criamos uma cópia
está chan
fé de forma autônoma e invertemos e que
a tendência é eu não preciso ir até uma
máquina de café é máquina de café que
vai até mim e portanto é claramente uma
brincadeira que ganhou uma dimensão
superior é foi um sucesso não é
precisamente hoje em dia de alta é
compactada mundial momento para mostrar
os seus robôs porque felizmente
conseguiu se que uma grande uma grande
dimensão
por outro lado criamos é é um
utilitarismo sim
criamos um robô chamado cleiton em que o
objetivo é usar serviços às pessoas é
facilitar o acesso ao serviço das
pessoas por exemplo numa loja do cidadão
que é um deles só seja aplicado nesta
nesta faz tipicamente nós vamos tomar
uma decisão já com o pensamento que
vamos passar uma eternidade o wii
a nossa vida vai acabar a lei e portanto
é pra não dar importância vamos lembrar
um ano portanto e já temos isso
diretamente intrínseco dentro sempre
entrando em uma loja dessas e portanto
com roberto que nós quisemos fazer foi
não fazer as pessoas pra 30 pessoas
chega uma loja do cidadão porque eu vou
estar à sua espera é bonito tem os
olhinhos a tepco deve portanto ser
engraçado
a pessoa adquirir seu robô e eu vou
automaticamente já o serviço
por outro lado se não tiver o serviço um
curto prazo leva a pessoa até o balcão
onde efetivamente vai fazer o serviço e
com isso nós respeitamos a pessoa e
automaticamente dizem os olhos se
tiverem uma fila muito grande vai embora
porque eu enviei em que já passou pela
móvel é um sms com o tempo e quando
estiver quase a ser chamado de volta a
chamar o pai até mim
não podemos facilitar basicamente o
acesso à informação e também é um
serviço mas agora entramos aqui na
segunda parte da mensagem que eu queria
trazer já começar a espalhar pelo fim
ver ter começado porque mas que usar
exemplos concretos de como é que eu vou
falar a seguir
efetivamente é possível que é a robótica
tecnologia não não não mais de todo não
for não está a ser feito de tudo para
nos substituir na sociedade
ela tem que ser visto como um
complemento como uma ajuda é e portanto
temos que deixar de ter imenso
oficial da robótica está a ser feita
para substituir na ala
ela só vai fazer e que o tipo 1 a loja
não queremos fazer e por outro lado vai
fazer coisas que nós mandamos que ela
faça e portanto ela não está de todo
para não substituir por outro lado
também não vai ferir
não tem como é verdade nós podemos
pensar e temos alguns casos de que
efetivamente a tecnologia fez mal mas
não foi até um jeito fez mal foi absurda
uma nova aquela tecnologia que utilizou
de forma errada e portanto somos nós
fazemos mal uns dos outros não é
tecnologia robótica que vai fazer uns
aos outros então não tem por muito tempo
diz a oficial e tem a capacidade de
pensar
ela só vai fazer mal se assim for
programada para tal portanto ela não
tome natureza por iniciativa própria não
irá fazer nunca
por outro lado ela não vai controlar
quem controla o que nos poderá controlar
é o nosso sistema político são as
pessoas etc
não é claramente está com os ricos vai
controlar não é o facebook nos controla
quem programou provavelmente o facebook
poderá ter em tendência de nos controlar
a tecnologia por si nunca o irá fazer
portanto a tecnologia a robótica em si
precisa ser simples nós precisamos de
interagir com esses modelos e com isso
novos paradigmas de forma simples e
portanto temos que complicar claramente
e tem produtos tecnologia que produz
robot quem nós começamos a desenhar um
roubo em temos de ter sempre esse
suposto por trás que é ela tem que ser
símbolos um carrinho de compras por uma
pessoa como da rodovia por um idoso para
uma grávida e quer que seja
não não podem exigir que a pessoa saiba
pois aula e portanto ela tem que ser
fácil
um simples carro do então eu comecei a
fazer minhas compras e portanto tem que
ser uma coisa prática simples
por outro lado robótica tem que ter
sentimento e não falo quando eu falo que
a robótica tem que ter sentimento não é
sentimentos humanos
ela tem que proporcionar sentimentos
bons têm que nos ajudar efetivamente
presente é nesse ponto de vista que eu
acredito e robótica
recentemente pode gerar sentimentos
positivos em nós e já vou contar algumas
histórias que aconteceram é mais
profissional com a transição da nossa
tecnologia
por outro lado o movimento como tudo na
vida robô tem que ter um propósito
não podemos é verdade nós somos
cilindrados certa forma somos invadidos
por tecnologia que nós olhamos para ele
dizendo sim mas este ataque e compramos
na mesma mesmo serve para muito mais
efetivamente robótica de um jeito em ter
um propósito ela tem que ser criada e
quem está a desenvolver
tem que sentir assim fico lá a dizer que
o problema efetivamente nós por exemplo
a empresa quando estávamos a desenhar
uma filosofia que cada colaborador que
entrava dentro da minha equipa tinha que
passar pelo menos um dia inteiro sentado
em uma cadeira de balanço que tenha
circulado na mesma perceber porque é que
o produto qualquer proposta que o
produto e e sentia que efetivamente o
movimento o fato de tirar uma compra o
fato ter colocado num saco o facto de
ter ajuda para transportar o seu saco
era um problema portanto resolvemos
parte do deixe esta problemática
dessa forma e portanto eu sou um
defensor claro que a tecnologia robótica
tem que ter um propósito e sem isso não
serve para rigorosamente nada
tal como o nosso todos nós temos que ser
fáceis
uns para com os outros têm que ser
amáveis temos que ter um propósito viria
robótica e tecnologia tem que ser vista
é assim tem que efetivamente é ser é e
ajudarmos no nosso dia a dia
nunca esqueçam de uma coisa é eu coloco
sempre esta fraco pra mim faz sentido
atualmente para as pessoas sem qualquer
limitação física é a tecnologia torna as
coisas fáceis mas por uma pessoa com
dificuldades para uma pessoa como dar
vida à tecnologia thomaz koch possíveis
e isto é grande diferença
isto é o propósito a tecnologia é tornar
as coisas fáceis e possíveis
vamos lá contar apenas nos últimos dois
minutos conca estão contados apenas duas
histórias que aconteceram em dois
pilotos que nós fizemos aqui indo aí
curiosamente é nós estamos com com a
sonae dentro do do continente gaia é a
nossa tecnologia e não dos testes logo
na primeira semana apareceu uma senhora
idosa chaco já com que andava às
canadianas e portanto vá você tem
debaixo do do braço e é muito difícil
convencer alguém como garfo sido um
idoso que não sabe nada a tecnologia
utilizada no roubo
nós conseguimos começamos a senhora de
sempre olha não se importa em utilizar
estamos aqui a tentar colocar essa
tecnologia está muito a sua ajuda para
tal já aceitou logo ensinando aplicamos
como é que ele tecnologia funcional e
ela o atleta não está o robô acontecer
eu acho que o seu caminho estrangeiro
mas vamos da manhã
a senhora era típica senhora que
efetivamente por um homem que morava
sozinho e estava mais longe tinha
claramente é vivida de forma isolada
certa forma portanto o facto de ir às
compras
eram momentos elas se distrair e
portanto aquela senhora foi fazer as
suas compras corroborou a volta do
meio-dia já tenha um saco acham mais
autonomia para o roubo na zona da
restauração
dentro do centro do continente e para o
enfrentamento e nos tocando bateria não
há qualquer problema
vamos vamos continuar senhora pega no
tabuleiro de como ele vai sentar se
literalmente enfrenta o robô e diálogo
roubo roubo
obviamente não respondia eu estava ali
para transportar as compras da vale pra
falar com ela naturalmente mas o gol não
o gesticulou não fez nada e portanto é o
vila e ela acabou solto mina e voltou
fazer suas compras no final ela escolhe
pela primeira vez na vida eu fiz compras
de forma confortável e fiz compras é é
acompanhado e isso me ajudou me imenso
voltou a semana assim que voltou a
utilizar outro exemplo rápidas e tem
apenas dez pontos mas
é outro exemplo rápido havia um senhor
foi às compras com sua esposa sua esposa
estava em pé de igualdade
conseguimos convencê-lo o senhor levava
um saco debaixo do braço e acabou por
fazer um simples fax compras e demorou
cerca de cinco horas a fazer compras
porque como é que o senhor fazia compras
com sua esposa é que o espaço eu eu acho
uma técnica incrível então basicamente
que eu fazia com que a gente compra
convencional como cavol entre a casa das
rosas em prova os dois que portanto em
prova o carro em compras ao mesmo tempo
que buscava a sua esposa com quem em
compras que fazer uma ginástica incrível
150 anos
isso porque nós vimos aqui encher a
linguagem do saco a um solto e se passou
cinco horas o senhor no final quase em
lágrimas só nos diz kim nem nos portões
de entrada por - as pessoas importantes
- muito obrigado porque pela primeira
vez fiz compras em para minha esposa e
olhar nos olhos sempre escolher um
produto isto que haviam cinco anos desde
que eu não fazia isto e é isso que eu ia
ajudar as pessoas a ajudar a aproximar
as pessoas e é assim que nós temos
também ser uns com os outros a
aproximar-nos é falar as coisas não
temos medo de ajudar e não temos medo de
ser um volante com todos muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]